todos unidos contra el primer ministro
de turquía el viernes 9 grupos rebeldes
unificados bajo el nombre de frente
unido de fuerzas federalistas y
confederalistas de qiu quienes
declararon que juntaran sus fuerzas
contra el oficialismo a response
esta alianza se forma en respuesta a las
numerosas crisis del país para revertir
los efectos negativos del gobierno de
abiyán meant en el pueblo de etiopía y
en otros lugares por feaps envió a los
distintos grupos son poco conocidos al
igual que sus capacidades reales serían
procedentes de diferentes religiones y
etnias sobre el terreno los rebeldes del
frente de liberación del pueblo de tigre
y de lola un grupo romo ya habían
declarado la unión de sus tropas y
habían afirmado tener el control de dos
ciudades estratégicas a unos 300
kilómetros de la capital addis abeba una
ciudad que se prepara para una según
militares además de la declaración de
reciente del estado de emergencia
nacional y de una movilización de
hombres y armas el viernes ex soldados y
reservistas fueron llamados a las filas
sin embargo el gobierno sigue negando al
avance del enemigo mientras los llamados
a la paz de la comunidad internacional
siguen sin escucharse el conflicto en
etiopía debe terminar las negociaciones
de paz deben comenzar inmediatamente sin
condiciones previas para lograr un alto
al fuego desde hace un año chupi ya
vivió una guerra civil que según la unió
ha dejado miles de muertos y ha obligado
a dos millones de civiles a abandonar
sus hogares